you know there's show business and then
there's
you know real every once in a while you
meet a real human being that touches
your heart
above and beyond the talent what what a
what a tragedy gene thanks so much for
joining us tonight we appreciate it um
clearly a heavy heart tonight at losing
your friend
eddie van halen what did eddie mean to
you
i don't even think it's fair to say my
friend
i saw them as a new band that i'd never
heard of for they i was off
i was invited to go see them at a place
called the starwood
1977 something like that and i was
upstairs in the oh you're so special
area and people are coming over for
autographs and then i
heard this astonishing sound the guitar
that just sounded like three or four
guitar players all playing at the same
time what is that
and melodic and in harmony too and i
went to the front and i saw this guy
like tapping away on his guitar which
i've never seen before and of course
the elite singers define gravity flying
in the air and the
great alex on drums and michael on base
you know
just uh but this one guitar was making
all this
sound and i'd never heard anything like
that and i have to say
today was kind of heartbreaking uh
not just for myself but for millions and
millions of fans van halen's had over
the years
and for so many guitar players that
eddie influenced
[Music]
i want to ask you about do you have a
favorite moment with eddie since you
were there in the beginning
i was just honored and lucky enough to
be there to witness the greatness before
it exploded on the world
okay i was in the studio with them i
produced their demo iii
all about me me me which is what i
usually do
i i saw a s more powerful than a
speeding
bullet you know able to leap tall
buildings i saw it
i didn't discover superman he was always
there just i just happened to be there
when they exploded on the scene nobody's
been like them
to this day you know when i was a kid
and i heard jimi hendrix for the first
time
okay earth has changed not since jimi
hendrix has anybody had
that effect do you do you have a
favorite memory
with eddie i uh
yeah kiss was in the studio and van
halen had already become a very big band
and eddie was unhappy within the band
every band goes through that
and eddie called and said that he wanted
to come down and
you know to tell to tell me that he
wasn't happy with
some members in the band doesn't matter
and he wanted to join kiss
and i said no you're not going to do
that let's go have lunch and we're going
to talk about this thing and
he was so unhappy with you know the
personalities within the band sometimes
it's good sometimes not and
he just couldn't take it anymore i i you
can't leave the band it's called van
halen
you're the main songwriter in the band
and
it's it's your bad you gotta you gotta
do that and he didn't
and you know he stuck it out before he
left
he sat the rest of the guys in kiss down
paul myself you know the rest of the
guys in the van
hey let me play you uh this thing we
just did
going well that's what's cool what is
that uh synthesizer he goes yeah
yeah it's called uh you know jump and oh
that's cool great
hey when are you going to add the lead
guitar and the guitars goes no that's it
you're van halen you're going to release
a synth i got to tell you he knew it
the rest of us were just in the peanut
gallery waiting hey where's the same old
stuff
what would you say will be eddie's
lasting legacy
especially in music and especially for
guitarists the greeks have a
phrase for it to thine own self be true
the great runners you know who are speed
past you bolt and everybody else they
don't look over their shoulder to see
who else is running or who's beside them
they just
they speed along their own way at their
own speed that's what makes him a
champion
and he respected everybody else but he
was his own guy
to the end and i don't even have the
right to make an assessment i'm not part
of the van halen family
i just happened to see as the greatness
sort of passed me by
you know i'd not i saw them when they
were
like little kids i saw that it's uh
you know it's still heartbreaking i
don't know what to say but eddie really
was one of those guys who could
who could do it all there was nothing
that was it seemed like there was
nothing he couldn't do
he also was beloved in hollywood you
know he was one of those rockers that
also could immerse himself in hollywood
he was married to valerie for so long
and
people in hollywood seem to embrace and
love him too
but but eddie was unaffected by that as
you can
well imagine the red carpet and you guys
with your cameras and stuff eddie never
cared about that stuff okay so
my wife's uh you know the sitcom and
stuff that's cool hey how you doing
very matter of fact uh
it's humbling he could teach all of us a
lesson and just how to
you know relax be a human being first
above and beyond what you do
i want to ask you about van halen as a
band and when they rose and they
eventually would become
the number one band in the world for a
while there
and that was driven by that monstrous
sound that eddie could
those crazy sounds that could come out
of that guitar and people marveled at
him
but you mentioned he still remained this
humble and simple guy
despite the fact that he was this
massive rock star
he was unaffected and could care less
about the fame
and he was always just kind of eddy and
wasn't trying to impress anybody
and uh it's it's humbling
he would uh he could outplay anybody
and never had the heirs of
okay watch out here i come none of that
stuff
it's it is uh it's got to be
heartbreaking for the family my heart
goes out
prayers to his family friends and of
course there's millions of fans
i i would urge everybody out there who
knows
gen z kids and millennials
grab him by the ear pull him over
to something called a record player and
let him hear van halen
hey gene i want to also ask you about
this battle for eddie has been going
on for quite some time he was even
traveling to europe
um were you keeping up with him as he
was traveling in what exactly was he
fighting against eddie despite the fact
that he got
the most horrible disease out there
cancer
i wasn't there to see it personally but
out on the street because i ran into him
a few times even after he
got the cancer scare
and he'd greet you with an open smile
like he didn't have a care in the world
you know the phrase god bless him is
aptly directed
at eddie you know there's show business
and then there's
you know real every once in a while you
meet a real human being that touches
your heart
above and beyond the talent what what a
what a tragedy how how
how amazing was it that he got to spend
those years
traveling with wolfgang his son and
he was part of the band and those two
were together and you
you have you know your son your brother
right behind you and you're playing the
music you love what did that mean to
eddie
right i i'm sure for the van halen
family it
must have been a great source of pride
alex eddie and
wolfie in the same band coming that's
what you uh
family is everything at the end of the
day and uh to see your son
and you know as a bass player and you
know i know the good stuff
that kid's got the goods and you watch
the whole band on stage rocking out and
it's a it's
got to be a source of pride listen gene
thank you so much for talking about your
good
about eddie and what he meant to the
world because
today we did lose a genius and an
originator an
icon of the music world and there will
be no one else who will ever
innovate like eddie more importantly for
me
a real beautiful soul that's his biggest
[Music]
achievement